# This video will hurt #
Wear your headphones Please, I promise you that there are no loud sounds but this
The video will hurt you. There is a study on ultrasound and how to cause headaches
These are more audible than those added to this video
But it causes a headache anyway,
The ultrasonic wave in your headphones presses on your inner ear, pressing on the connecting nerves
For your mind where the headache does not start yet, it will start shortly after exposure to the waves
It causes headaches 10 seconds later
.Oh my God
Feel it? That pressure on your ears is spread to your beaver's mind?
because you are
You are not supposed to feel it: that study is artificial and there is no ultrasound in this video
However, some of you started feeling headaches. Why? Because of the influence of Nosebo
Nusibu is harmless, such as video tags above fake audios, and causes the hurt
Like a headache, because you think it hurts. This may seem juggling though
There are scientific studies on the influence of Nosibu as it is more than a play trick
It causes real medical problems
When a new drug is tested, doctors get a group of patients and give half of them the new drug
While giving the other half a disc that does not have. Effect but tell them that it is a real medicine
Thus scientists discover what works from the nonsense that does not harm or benefit
However, modern properties have side effects and sometimes patients leave the study because of them
No surprise here
But also withdraw some people who take counterfeit real estate because of the side effects
Of a drug they do not take but because they believe they are taking it
They also believed they had side effects
Perhaps this is just a case of misinterpretation: people often get headaches and join a medical study
Remember that headache is a possible side effect. It is normal to link the headache to the new drug
This happens, of course
But the effect of Nosibu more than a misinterpretation is causing additional real damage and scientists can
Measured in very harsh experiments and this cruelty is one of the reasons for the lack of abundance
Of research on harmful phantom drugs as they progressed to the Board of Ethical Review of Research
With research designed specifically for human beings would reject it. But Nusibu tests are sometimes believed
For the benefit of science and humanity, but not for the benefit of the participants
For example, under the right conditions when some people expect to get rashes
My skin from a syringe with harmful effects will get swollen but when they expect nothing to happen, no
Something happens completely
Cereals may become addicted, if participants are cut off on a pill they think is addicted
Some will experience symptoms of a mock withdrawal such as pain and exhaustion
Grains are impossible to add to the original
In another test I gave some people a harmless right and half of them were not told anything while it was said
The other half that the pain will intensify in the next half hour which has already happened
But in this test there was a drug that inhibited the effect of Nosebo and those
Who were told that the injection would hurt them and secretly gave the drug to the nussibu
Did not report an increase in pain, showing that the Nosebo effect was a physical process
Genuine
In all Nusseibu tests, the conviction that the hurt is what distinguishes. If you meet a magician
A sorcerer and curse this magician with the curse of pain, nothing will happen to you
But if you are with a doctor and his prescription, a medical machine and an injection
In your arm, you will take his words seriously
That's why doctors say "this will not hurt you" rather than "this will hurt you
Strongly "(by the way this was a test for women passing by
(Birth defects during spinal injection, you can imagine how this was done
But the effect of Nosibu is not only that, while diseases such as influenza spread from communication with humans
Infected with delinquents and touched by their nasty and spread hands, Nosebo spreads
From the mind to the other mind without any connection
A noteworthy example is what happened at a high school in Tennessee when I was informed of the Eshmat school
Strange smell in the separation and then began to show symptoms of headache and nausea and difficulty breathing
These symptoms spread to their students and to other students at school and ended
Visited about 200 people to the local hospital but the medical tests did not report anything,
I found nothing harmful about school
This was Nusibu, the belief that the air was sick and moved from one mind to another
And each of the disease had heard about the symptoms of another. When this happens he calls
Collective disease resulting from the mind
Treatment in these cases is the isolation of those suffering from these symptoms from the rest and reassure them
That their symptoms are real but they have not been exposed to anything toxic
And that people's situation is improving rapidly
This is the last indication of the evidence that separates a toxic gas leak or a biological weapon
Of the collective disease resulting from the mind, but the last factor is to increase the number of cases by increasing coverage of the news
These symptoms are very common
If, for example, people with electromagnetic susceptibility are those who feel nausea (and other symptoms) from exposure to some
Electromagnetic waves, especially wavelengths, which are increasingly used over time
Which makes some of those suffering from those symptoms strongly to retire to places with scary names such as the silence
(Radio in West Virginia) of course
However, if the electromagnetic susceptibility is placed in a room with it and it will not be able to know through
Their symptoms are if they are closed or open, but rather, they follow their symptoms if they are told
It is open or closed
Some people who do not suffer from electromagnetic susceptibility are forced to watch a news report
That Waiwai is sick while the other group see something non-educational and then
The two groups were shown on fake waves and some would only see those who watched the news report
The disease
There is a similar phenomenon claiming wind farm disease and have similar symptoms
Appear only where local news agencies are talking, not below
In the same country with the same wind farms
All of this makes it easy to mock those who think they get sick from the wifi
Or wind farms or wind farms by Yvai but it is necessary to realize that they are not crazy
Their symptoms are real but they are wrong about the source of these symptoms as all evidence suggests that
Electromagnetic susceptibility is the reason
Which means that news reports about these diseases are somehow published
While these are anomalous examples, there is also evidence that some allergies
And asthma caused by Nosebo and thus spread in the same way
For clarity: If you see someone getting an asthma attack this is not a good time to tell them that you are
You think they are hysterics because you saw a video on the internet about the effect of Nosebo
They really have asthma and really need something to stop
This is really not to boast of your knowledge
Harmful things are not harmful just because we think they are harmful as an adequate dose of arsenic
It will kill you just as it will kill you with an anvil on your head, no matter what you insist on
But Nussibu's influence shows us that our beliefs about things are not harmful
It makes them harmful
Which means that the curse of the witch doctor we mentioned before can actually hurt us but that
We are humpy enough to believe it